I
oh good evening everyone my name is
David Sullivan from the department of
clinical biochemistry at royal prince
alfred hospital in sydney and it's my
pleasure to participate in its this lab
roots webinar it's morning here in
Sydney Australia but I gather it's the
end of a long day for most of you have
been participating so thank you for your
patience and participating in this
particular webinar which is entitled
opportunities to simplify clinical lipid
assessment and but the object of this
particular webinar will be to look at
both our routine and our non-routine
lipid testing because there are changes
occurring which I think bring with them
the opportunity to have a simplified yet
more effective approach and we'll try to
look at that in a co-ordinated sort of a
way so what I'm going to do is to think
about routine lipid and lipoprotein
testing sorts of things such as
measurement of total cholesterol fasting
triglycerides HDL cholesterol and the
calculation of LDL cholesterol according
to the federal equation and try to
interface that with some changes in
advice in those fields and how it may
let us better utilize some of a non
routine testing those aspects such as
testing of apolipoproteins the use of
electro faradic techniques and moving on
to fields such as genotyping and
miscellaneous techniques such as gas
chromatography-mass spectrometry etc and
we will then think about how we use
these tests and how we and and how they
they can be a better better utilized for
a patient assessment if we ask ourselves
the question what are the modifiable
risk factors that affect cardiovascular
disease and some interesting information
has been derived from a large-scale
study
the inter have study looking at the case
control causes of myocardial infraction
not only in Western countries but also
in emerging economies and the results of
that study you can see demonstrated the
relevance of the classical
cardiovascular respecters things like
diabetes hypertension smoking etc and
you'll see the top of the list there was
the so-called fo b 2 fo a 1 ratio and in
this trial that was the means by which
it was attempted to assess the lipid
status of the participants oh that was
trying to capture both the atherogenic
and the anti atherogenic aspects of
Pilate protein profile and a palapa
protein measurement was chosen in an
attempt to accommodate non-fasting
samples and you can see that this topped
the list in terms of the odds ratio the
attributable risk and it also topped the
Soviet ratio and also topped the list of
the population attributable risk and was
contributing in nearly fifty percent of
cases this was largely because it was
felt that around about eighty percent of
the participants had non ideal lipid
profiles so it was a very major
contributor the other interesting thing
from this trial was that below the line
you see the first time statistical
evidence about the contribution of
things we've suspected as respect as but
haven't been able to prove in the past
things like abdominal obesity
psychosocial factors poor diet lack of
exercise and a slight beneficial effects
from alcohol but the main message from
this slide was the the prominence of
lipid risk factors and just
interestingly the use of apple
lipoprotein measurements in this
epidemiological study to try to capture
that so we try to approach each
individual patient with a standardized
sort of a
an approach which would allow us to
calculate the absolute risk of a
cardiovascular event in the next five
years and so first of all we see I can
give the arrow to point first of all we
try to assess the patient's
non-modifiable risk factors their gender
age maybe ethnicity etc next we try to
capture clinical modifiers of their
overall situation things like whether
about cardiovascular disease renal
disease diabetes etc we then introduce
the modifiable risk factors their blood
pressure whether they're smoking or not
etc and in the lipid component is also
incorporated particularly in terms of
their total and HDL cholesterol and with
these aspects it's possible to calculate
the absolute risk of an event in the
next five years and this of course can
then generate appropriate management
plans those management plans might start
with additional measurements that need
to be made and it's worthwhile stressing
that if the risk is in an intermediate
zone it's at this particular point that
additional measurements or whether they
be additional lipoprotein measurements
or other risk assessment measurements
such as c-reactive protein etc that they
might contribute to that process and out
of all this information a decision can
be made as to which particular
treatments are appropriate for that
individual patient and so an important
part of this process is measurement of
total cholesterol which will usually be
modified with the addition of
information about triglyceride and HDL
cholesterol to generate the free world
equation derived LDL cholesterol level
and so this is based on the assumption
that if we have a fasting sample we
vieni chylomicrons present you would
point out of course that column icons
are fairly poor and cholesterol and so
that should make that much difference
but it helps with the logic of the feed
world equation because you can then
assume that the total cholesterol is
made up of the combination of the
cholesterol and very low-density
lipoproteins trespassing row density
lipoproteins process in high-density
lipoproteins the first to being
atherogenic and the latter being anti
atherogenic we can then rearrange that
as equation so as to say that the LDL
cholesterol on the right-hand side is
going to be equal to the total
cholesterol minus for the LDL
cholesterol minus the HDL cholesterol if
we then make assumptions as to the
composition of bill the L particles been
for non SI units we divide the
triglyceride by five or four SI units /
triglyceride x 2.2 to derive the
appropriate free world equation that the
LDL cholesterol equals the total
cholesterol minus the HDL cholesterol
minus the triglyceride / 5 or 2.2
milligrams per deciliter or millimoles
per liter respectively and several
conclusions are actually evident from
this approach first of all it should be
evident that total cholesterol alone
when studied in isolation is inadequate
for assessing cardiovascular risk
because it contains both atherogenic and
anti heterogeneity protein
simultaneously the second point is that
when triglyceride is elevated that does
place limitations upon the free world
equation we may be running into a
situation where trova Tsarevich
lipoproteins with different composition
or present maybe kala microns or remnant
particles and this would invalidate the
feed world equation and it's also useful
reminder that when triglycerides
elevated there tends to be a reciprocal
relationship we should check that this
is the case a reciprocal relationship
high triglyceride tends to be associated
with lower
HDL and as we'll see in later slides
there are implications for the
composition of LDL particles themselves
which may not be so well captured by the
result of the calculation the LDL
cholesterol itself and finally and a
little slave this in the next slide
there are some new therapeutic
developments occurring which may
confound the Speedwell calculation of
LDL cholesterol and that's illustrated
on this slide here first of all in the
left-hand panel you can see some very
low LDL cholesterol levels that are
achieved with the new and pcsk9 antibody
therapies for cholesterol reduction here
we're getting down to LDL cholesterol
levels will below 40 milligrams per
deciliter well below 1 many more paleta
and you can see that as you get down to
these levels the the correlation between
calculated freed world LDL cholesterol
and gold standard ultracentrifugation
alee directly measured LDL cholesterol
is disconcertingly poor with really
really very unacceptable levels of
agreement and of course with the feed
wall being we compare it against the
gold standard the suggestion is that the
formula is not performing well under
those circumstances in the right hand
two panels you'll also see what happens
when we use a different class of drugs
known as cholesterol is to transfer
protein inhibitors first of all you can
see a very substantial change in LDL
cholesterol level and a really quite
astounding more than one hundred percent
change in HDL cholesterol level as
you'll see in the next slide this occurs
because of changes in physiology which
will alter the composition of most
lipoproteins particularly the
triglyceride which lipoproteins and so
our assumptions which underpin the free
world equation may well be undermined
and patients receiving this sort of
treatment would not be suitable
for free board equation LDL and in fact
when used in trials the federal equation
we're starting to generate negative
values for LDL cholesterol etc so
obviously inappropriate and most
patients and here you see the basis of
the action of cholesterol is to transfer
protein I'll just quickly highlight its
presence here so cholesterol is to
transfer protein is responsible for the
manner in which cholesterol can and in
lipids in the core of lipoproteins can
exchange down concentration pathways so
we have triglyceride which lipoproteins
which will lose triglyceride but have it
replaced with cholesterol from
cholesterol-rich lipoproteins and in the
process the triglyceride which
lipoproteins will become cholesterol
enriched but more importantly as we'll
see in a in following slides the
triglyceride in the cholesterol-rich
lipoprotein such as LDL will be
catabolized as fuel and will lead to
shrinkage and decreased in diameter in
those cholesterol-rich particles thereby
altering their composition density etc
and so the general rule is that when
triglyceride is elevated LDL cholesterol
may underestimate the number of
particles present and the risk of
cardiovascular disease is probably
driven more by the number of particles
than adeus boli absolute amount of
cholesterol and this is illustrated in
the Quebec Heart Study it illustrates
the measurement of so-called small dense
LDL which people are I think now
familiar with is a more at regenexx form
of LDL and however you can see in the
orange bars that when the LDL are small
and dense they do not constitute an
increase in cardiovascular risk unless
they are increased in numbers
the blue bars show you the situation
which the number of particles are
increased and so there is an increase in
risk both in small dents and in normal
composition LDL particles about a
two-fold increase in risk however the
most exaggerated increase in risk occurs
when there is both an increase in LDL
particle as where there is a decrease in
LDL particle size small dense LDL are
present but they are present in
increased numbers and you can see that
that constitutes nearly a six-fold
increase in risk and so small dense LDL
are only dangerous if there are too many
of them and the assumption behind the
the ability to assess the number of
particles views that there is one fo b
molecule to estrogen o'clock approaching
so a pelada protein B is a good method
for counting the number of particles the
main alternative that we have for
counting the number of LDL particles
consists of an NMR spectroscopy method
and when should consider non-hdl
cholesterol as possibly a practical
means by which we can approximate these
more sophisticated measures of LDL alpha
LDL particle number and one of the
consequences of this is if we use fo b
as a comparator if you like the gold
standard for assessing the number of LDL
particles we can look at the degree to
which different derived calculations can
approximate that measurement and if we
first of all look at LDL cholesterol a
usual marker of estrogen icity we see
that although there's good correlation
on the left-hand side the degree of
concordance is rather disappointing it
only around about fifty percent and it
is in fact surpassed by a much simpler
measurement the measurement of non-hdl
cholesterol
the difference between total and HDL
cholesterol and the correlation is
better and indeed the degree of
concordance is better with nearly a
two-to-one ratio in terms of favorable
agreement versus discordance and we are
now familiar with evidence that suggests
that when we take these different
measures that after Janice kiwi get
different results and so if we look at
the effect of LDL lowering therapies
you'll see that the amount of reduction
differs according to whether we've
measured LDL cholesterol non-hdl
cholesterol or fov a more flattering
sort of a result feel the old
cholesterol and for the other parameters
likewise agreeing includes measurement
of particle number by NMR again a less
flattering trigger again so if we want
to approach the proper assessment of our
interventions we probably need to use
these measurements which are more
directed towards LDL particle number and
and we see this again in assessment of
risk in this case from the US health
professional study we see that the
hazard ratio the risk ratio was greater
for non-hdl cholesterol and forever v
than it was for LDL cholesterol and in
prospective studies from the planning of
offspring study we can again get an
indication of the superior superiority
of particle number in comparison to LDL
cholesterol in the yellow mines you see
where there's agreement so we have a
yellow line of better survival in
patients who had both a low LDL
cholesterol and a low LDL particle
number we're survival in those with a
high LDL cholesterol at the high
particle number so that's where there is
concordance but where the results were
discordant you'll see that particle
number was superior
but we had better survival in those
patients who had a low LDL particle
number despite having a high LDL
cholesterol and we're survival in those
who had a high LDL particle number
despite having a low LDL cholesterol
number so again just pointing to the
superiority of LDL particle number / LDL
cholesterol we turn to the next
component of our routine assessments the
HDL cholesterol there are a couple of
conceptual issues here first of all
there is the possibility clinically of
having patients with high HDL
cholesterol levels and of course that
would confound the assumption that
anyone with a high cholesterol has a
high level of risk there there are quite
a number of these patients often older
female patients will have very high HDL
levels as part of a higher total
cholesterol but we're at the same time
we're also starting to see the emergence
of a bit of a debate as to whether all
HDL is good and so it may not
necessarily be the case that we can rely
on the ratio between total and HDL
cholesterol to assume a lack of estrogen
icity it may well be that HDL varies in
functionality I think this is still open
to debate this is largely the product of
the results from some of the trials with
cholesterol is to transfer protein
inhibitors where the expected
cardiovascular disease benefit was not
achieved however that has to something
really been thought to be due to the
lack of the presence of off target
effects and stars of the individual
drugs were concerned so thinking more
particularly about the management
measurement aspects of HDL cholesterol
we do have a basic reference method
which is
the precipitation of Adobe containing
lipoproteins with dextran sulfate
magnesium however we've moved to
so-called direct methods which have been
validated against the reference against
the designated comparison method and
they've been through a number of
different iterations the early essays
had quite a few reagents and complex
procedures and eventually required
simplification came down to using a
smaller number of reagents often
involving alpha cyclodextrin and there
was an improvement in HDL performance
based on the fact that these methods
were automated rather than sending
automated and and therefore more
reproducible however they all hinged on
the concept that what was happening was
that the reagents were leading to a
selective availability of only HDL
cholesterol for measurement barbour
particular analytes and so the a lot of
this depends on the actual selectivity
of the of the methods themselves and
this is seen on this particular slide
that the concept is that the reagents
code both the lipoproteins and the
cholesterol esterase and the cholesterol
oxidase and they prevent interaction
between these reagents and LDL and vldl
particles but leave it accessible to the
black dogs mainly the HDL particles
however this selectivity is not absolute
and as the package insert explains there
is no model available that can we make
experience by triglycerides and
triglyceride levels and patient
specimens behave unpredictably and in
our experience this has led to a
phenomenon where the
assays that were common in the mid 2000s
they may have been updated since then
but at that stage there was a
demonstrable interference with the
direct HDL methods via triglyceride rich
lipoproteins it was evident that it was
reduced HDL recovery in
hypertriglyceridemia suggesting positive
interference that that could mask low
HDL and cases of hypertriglyceridemia it
was slightly abolished rim the Alpha
cyclodextrin methods were reintroduced
but subsequently formulations of the FA
may well have got around this problem to
a large degree however it's worth
cautioning that most external QC samples
are spiked with concentrations
containing all hyper proteins and so the
usual inverse relationship between
triglyceride which lipoproteins HDL is
not evidence because they they are
increased in parallel in the Quality
Assurance samples and therefore the the
interference may not be may not be
evident if we think about next standard
or routine laboratory lipid assessment
that will be the measurement of
triglyceride here there are a couple of
principles to keep in mind about the
essay of course fatty acids which might
be present in triglyceride can vary in
molecular weight and therefore they may
not be suitable for the standardization
of the essay however the glycerol
backbone there is one molecule per
triglyceride molecule and that would be
a more suitable target for for the essay
techniques however it needs to be
remembered that there are other good
soil based biological lipids most
particularly phospholipids and so as we
perform the essay we are making
assumptions we're measuring the glycerol
but we're making assumptions about the
relative lack of into
glyceryl and we're also making
assumptions about the generation of
glycerol virus a lipase and its
specificity for triglyceride as compared
to lecithin but the more important issue
I think as far as triglyceride
measurement is concerned is the question
of the need for a 12 hour fast prior to
measurement this is a component of
standardization of the essay it avoids
the presence of chylomicrons which as
we've seen as an assumption from the
free the world equation and of course it
standardizes triglyceride against the
presence of dietary triglyceride for the
measurement of measurement of
triglycerides of a diagnosis of
hypertriglyceridemia so the we've
reached the stage however where and it
seems that it might actually be some
advantages from measuring non-fasting
triglyceride first of all it seems to be
more sensitive as a marker of
cardiovascular risk and even as a marker
of total mortality also you can make a
point that it doesn't that the failures
of fast does not have a huge impact on
total or LDL or low HDL cholesterol
where does have a modest impact on HDL
cholesterol and this slide illustrates
for you the superiority of non-fasting
as compared to fasting triglyceride
levels for the and for the assessment of
risk of myocardial infarction
cardiovascular disease and total
mortality in men and women as you see
the increasing risk across quintiles and
the most effective measurements were
tend to be those which were taken about
four hours after the previous meal
and so if we try to weigh up the pros
and cons of postprandial measurement
could we have a standardized
measurements that actually tested us in
the fat in the non fasting state we'd
have to think about the composition of
the food and the amount that was given
we'd have to think about whether a
physiological in terms of comparison to
what the eve of a daily basis whether
there was a contribution from the diet
and the hours or days beforehand whether
there was a modification according to
gastric emptying time which might theory
with different foods that be questions
about what to measure and went measure
it and there be also the question of how
to present the data which particular
time points would that the combination
of time points and any ways of becoming
rather equivalent to the glucose
tolerance test and probably the main
interest is in the specificity of
markers of of the postprandial space
measurement of the specific
apolipoprotein be 48 or of the marker
retinol esta however it may be
worthwhile pursuing these particular
objectives because it may well be that
the postprandial state is more
atherogenic and that we're only going to
appreciate that if we study non-fasting
samples this after Jenna City may have
to do with the facts of dietary
cholesterol it may be influenced by
competition for LDL receptor clearance
with familiar that dodgy particles
probably activate factor seven and the
coagulation Cascades we would think
about the role of chylomicron remnants
in the actual formation of plaque and
we're familiar with quite substantial
changes in vascular reactivity that may
occur in the postprandial state so as we
try to weigh out the pros and cons and I
think we have to preserve a role for
fasting measurement and because
otherwise the test of triglyceride is
under standardized in turn
of its details and therefore we
therefore we do require a fast example
if we're going to be calculating LDL
cholesterol fiber freed world equation
or if we're going to be attempting to
diagnose or monitor hypertriglyceridemia
however there may be a lot of situations
where we are using fasting samples at
the moment where am on fasting sample
may be completely adequate for instance
it would appear to be adequate to supply
a total at HDL cholesterol level for
inclusion in risk calculators secondly
it should be adequate for the
calculation of non-hdl cholesterol and
as we've seen that non-hdl cholesterol
is superior to LDL cholesterol for risk
calculation and therefore it is likely
as we move to a to a greater use of
non-hdl cholesterol that we should be
familiar with the sort of conversion for
the most part a non-hdl cholesterol
target will be around about eight
million more sorry 0.8 millimoles per
liter higher than an LDL the card LDL
cholesterol targets I'm sorry that this
slide looks like it's distorted a little
bit but having dealt with the routine
test so now like to spend a little bit
of time thinking about the non routine
tests and how they would interface with
the changes that we've mentioned so far
we've already pointed out that in the
inner heart study the fod to FLA one
measurements were reused as they attempt
to compensate for non-fasting
measurement of the patients and I think
there could be a debate about whether
that was necessary we've seen that you
can maybe we can measure lipids
non-fasting as well and with the
epilogue of proteins offer any ability
to get down but on fasting stage I think
is
a bit open to debate the we've already
discussed the superior superiority of
that OB / LDL cholesterol the question
as to whether ratios of any sort
superior to 10 the other i think is also
debatable they do make the assumptions
about the protective nature of HDL on fo
a one which was i've said is under
question and i think the the role of
ratios is has really been an
epidemiological convenience of combining
two separate independent risk factors
simultaneously and the advantages of
doing that I think may not be so
significant as we first thought there is
a clear role I think for the use of fo
be based on its superiority over LDL
cholesterol but we'll look at the issues
for everyone in them in a minute and i
think there's less evidence for the need
to separately measure fo a1 and amongst
the other routine apolipoproteins and
absurd that their function may be a bit
blurred here on the screen apart from
the fov the main other epilogue opposing
which may come to have a diagnostic role
is fo c 3 measurement which has quite a
close association with triglyceride
levels we said that we'd look separately
at the potential for superiority of FO a
1 over HDL that's been looked at as a
number of studies and really the result
to be mixed that in some of those
studies HDL cholesterol has being
superior to fo at one and the nearly
equal number of studies which FLA ones
being superior to HDL so I think the
conclusion that there isn't a strong
case for FLA one being superior to HDL
therefore a question as to whether it's
separate measurement
is justified one Apple apoprotein which
would appear to be of major diagnostic
significance is lipoprotein little a
abbreviated sometimes to LP little a and
its main distinguishing feature is that
is an LDL particle to which the unique
apolipoprotein that is Apple lipoprotein
little a is attached and so being based
on an LDL of course it contains m.o.b
but in addition there is this covalently
linked a PO little a leading to the LP
little a particle the appt own little a
molecule is genetically polymorphic it
varies greatly in the number of Kringle
for type 2 repeats and of course this
polymorphism likely saw the triglyceride
and fatty acids this polymorphism has
major implications for the
standardization of measurement the other
thing about the overlay molecule is that
it has sequence homology to players
managin and is therefore likely to
interfere with spontaneous thrombolysis
and indeed post imogen also affect other
biological activities such as TGF alpha
tgf and therefore may have other
biological effects we are now familiar
with the idea that the cutoff for an
increase in cardiovascular risk may
occur around the 70s to 80s percentile
and people above this level may have an
independent cardiovascular risk from
there increase tell people a level and
up to this point in time routine drug
therapy has not been particularly
successful in addressing this however
nice and has some utility and
interestingly recently introduced mobile
agents sent to also be effective in
lowering healthy little a therefore it
will become more relevant to measure
this entity
now it looks like some treatment options
will be available in those people
identified as having a problem the
problem with LP little a may come from a
variety of server illogical mechanisms
many of these you would say are
equivalent to the antigenicity of the
LDL particle itself but in addition the
LP little a rule specifically inhibit
plasminogen and interfere with
thrombolysis this protein will also
cause it to interact with collagen and
proteoglycans and the vessel wall making
it more likely to be retained and
oxidized and its biological activities
via tgf-beta may also enhance atheroma
formation may also influence the the
death and deliberation of macrophages so
plenty of potential for LP was laid to
to be more atherogenic then it's LDL
equivalent this slide shows the
phenomenon of the increase in risk of
cardiovascular disease and formed on
fatal mio Cara death and carrying beyond
a level of around about 300 milligrams
per deciliter which would comprise the
30 70th to 80th percentile and this this
increase in cardiovascular risk persists
after adjustment for standard risk
factors most notably the lipoprotein
risk factors so it would appear to be an
independent risk factor for
cardiovascular disease and it is further
confirmed as an independent risk factor
by the technique of Mendelian
randomization in this technique both
there is concordance between the
cardiovascular risk associated with
increased plasma levels and also
increased risk associated with a genetic
pattern which would predict increased
plasma levels and so this is confirming
the likelihood of a causative
relationship between increased helping
delay and cardiovascular risk if we
continue to consider the non-routine
like a protein and lipid tests we can
think of a handful of
electrophoretically eeks which are used
for cardiovascular disease assessment
this have been used for a very sustained
period of time they were one of the
earliest investigations may form the
basis of the friedrichsen classification
or wh 0 classification for
hyperlipidemia and this was
traditionally generated from
electrophoresis on support media such as
agarose and he was possible to identify
which particular lipoprotein class was
accumulating however most of that
information can usually be inferred from
just the basic lipids and lipoproteins
results the total of cholesterol
triglycerides HDL they usually enough to
infer which particular market proteins
might be accumulating and the
electrokinetic pattern itself doesn't
really tell us much about the etiology
or the risk of future cardiovascular
events so there's been more of an
emphasis on trying to add clinical
information which would lead to the
recognition of the etiology of that
particular dis lipid Enoch patent and
were likely the likelihood of it being a
single gene disorder or a particular
clinical syndrome and so the presence of
elevated Carla microns alone would
ensure that we are dealing with
but in lipase deficiency the presence of
a broad beta band of remnant
lipoproteins would suggest that we're
dealing with a pony to e2 homozygosity
and and so the emphasis is like lying
more towards the identification of these
particular syndromes and that leaves us
with the difficulty that just the waho
classification method may not
distinguish between two situations where
the pattern is similar about the degree
of risk is quite different and so in the
pack of pure elevation of beta
lipoproteins that could be a polygenic
calls which would constitute some degree
of cardiovascular risk but the pattern
wouldn't distinguish it from familial
hypercholesterolemia in which the risk
is very much more substantially
increased and so the emphasis nowadays
is to try to identify the clinical
syndromes and to quantify their severity
and this will often hinge on other
measurements such as a pen LDL
quantitative LDL non-hdl cholesterol all
most importantly fov and here you see an
algorithm in which a Toby triglyceride
and cholesterol are used for the
prediction of which lipoprotein classes
are accumulating and then using that as
a prompt to consider which particular
syndrome of dyslipidemia may be present
and you can see under LDL have
highlighted the possibility of familial
hypercholesterolemia or its variance due
to mutations of fo b or a pcsk9 gene
where these represent particularly high
risk situations and so when we use this
approach to try to identify single gene
abnormalities
causes of primary dyslipidemia it's here
that we might have other non routine
tests that required to back up the
diagnosis this is where we might need to
measure lipoprotein lipase activity to
diagnose its absence where we might need
to met to do isoelectric focusing to try
to visualize FOC to which may be
deficient causing a similar sort of
syndrome I've mentioned the genetic
mutations which could be occurring to
cause familial hypercholesterolemia we
might also look at the gene pattern for
a PO a phenotype or genotype to explain
the presence of remnant particles or
alternatively right need to measure
hepatic lipase activity for that and so
there are there are a number of
sophisticated protein and molecular
techniques which might be required to
generate the the final diagnosis out of
all of those potential diagnoses I'd
like to spend a little bit of time just
emphasizing the importance of familial
hypercholesterolemia because this is the
most common potentially fatal genetic
condition with the prevalence between
one in 250 and one in 500 the it
constitutes a dominant mutation
affecting LDL receptor activity either
through the LDL receptor gene all
through its ligand fo b or through fine
tuning chaperones such as pcsk9 it leads
to an increase in LDL which accelerates
cardiovascular disease by about 20 to 40
years and unfortunately it's poorly
diagnosed particularly in countries that
lack a public health campaign based on
what's known as family Cascades screened
so first of all just to look at what
family Cascade screening is this is
actually the assessment of first-degree
relatives of an effective
case and here you can see tracing down a
family tree that with the dominant
condition like this that we end up with
about fifty percent of relatives being
affected and and example of of the
efficiency of this sort of an approach
is that a program in the UK screen two
hundred relatives and in the process
detected 121 cases and to do that by a
broad population screening program you
would have been to screen around 60,000
members of the general population the
experience in Holland where this
approach is widely used is that within
four years testing the relatives an
index case usually yields an average of
eight new cases and of course eight
other people could be reassured that
they they don't have a problem is really
a hypercholesterolemia so this is an
important public health issue the risks
are accumulating from birth there's
evidence that patients with the
condition you get cardiovascular disease
sub clinically before puberty eventually
it accounts for at least five percent of
premature cardiovascular disease and
it's untreated fifty percent of men with
this conditional developed clinical
cardiovascular disease by age 50 the
treatment and management is highly
cost-effective and so this is a field
where we we need to improve the synergy
between population health and molecular
genetics so the comments been made that
a few specialized nurses genetic field
workers etc working in close
collaboration with collisions could work
miracles just to confirm the argument
that this condition accelerates
cardiovascular disease by around about
twenty to forty years if we compare men
with and without saying it should be
should be there men with them without fh
you can see that on a horizontal axis
they're separated by around about
240 years and the same is true of women
with and without familial
hypercholesterolemia again separated by
a 20 to 40 years as I said before the
treatment is highly effective there's no
dedicated trial for this but if you
amalgamate patients in individual trials
you can get the impression of around
about a seventy-six percent reduction in
cardiovascular event rates and that this
becomes cost-effective actually
cost-saving after about four to five
years and so best practice involves that
strategy of family cascade screening
which is conducted in countries like
Holland UK Norway etc pen and it largely
commences with the identification of an
index case so first member of a family
identified with the condition and this
can be assisted by clinical tools such
as the Dutch clink Dutch lipid clinic
score it will strength for you in the
right-hand panel their countries who are
applying this this approach have
detected between twenty and fifty
percent of the affected individuals in
their populations and then they can
treat them with evidence-based
cost-effective guidelines and I think
the main message out of this is that
genetic techniques are used in this
setting but the genetic techniques are
more a tool for assisting family cascade
screening rather than representing a
definitive diagnostic test for a single
individual and so the genetic techniques
here should be regarded as a tool rather
than as a test unfortunately many other
countries and where I live in Australia
would be an example and I think it's
probably fairly similar in the u.s. that
we haven't applied family cascade
screening as a wide widely used health
strategy and therefore detection rates
down around five percent or
less and this is tragic because you can
see that there's evidence that
cardiovascular disease dose start in
childhood and here you see an
illustration of the rate of increase in
thickening of the carotid arteries in
young children with FH compared to the
rate of progression in the general
population and so the US has actually
approached this by having an alternative
strategy and so in the US the guidelines
after Universal screening of children
and I'm not sure of it's widely
appreciated that the strategy here was
particularly to address not only the
metabolic consequences of childhood
health childhood obesity which is such a
problem but also as a widespread myth
method for trying to take children with
FH and bring them into inter management
in a timely fashion one of the
initiatives that can be helpful at a
national level is the consideration of
using pathology reports to flag very
high levels you might think that
cholesterol greater than 7.5 millimoles
or 300 milligrams per deciliter although
it'd be more appropriate to use non
confounded measures such as LDL
cholesterol or non-hdl cholesterol but
if we flag those results maybe we can
direct clinicians towards diagnostic
tools and do a better job of detecting
index cases again just that
moving back to other forms of
electrophoresis we talked about
electrophoresis the diagnostic reasons
electrophoresis is also used as a
gradient gel technique for sizing LDL
particles and you'd be familiar with the
so-called pattern a pattern B assessment
of LDL particle size measurement ability
or particle size may give the impression
of a quantitative result but really it
is a qualitative result because of
although it's telling us particle
diameter it's not telling us particle
number as I stressed before the main
issue as far as a surgeon icity is
particle number I think it's worthwhile
recognizing that issues to do with LDL
particle size LDL density etc are
largely driven by triglyceride and we've
highlighted the role of cholesterol is
to transfer protein before but you'll
appreciate that it's really the amount
of triglyceride present in terms of
triglyceride which lipoproteins like the
LDL which drives the lipid exchange
which removes the cholesterol familiar
of HDL and which replaces it with
triglyceride which is then consumed
leading to the action of lipase to
generate a small dense LDL particle so a
two-step process where the cholesterol
is exchanged for triglyceride and the
triglyceride is removed and therefore we
might mainly expect to see small dense
LDL particles in patients in whom the
triglyceride level is elevated and this
just means that there would be a
question as to the value of doing LDL
particle size in situations where
triglyceride elevate elevation is not
present and in many ways LDL particle
size may just represent a surrogate for
mr. Owen and the relationship between
LDL particle size and triglyceride is
particularly strong if you look at the
postprandial triglyceride levels as a
predictor of LDL particle size again
with non-routine testing and thinking
about triglyceride related issues one of
the more sophisticated tests we could do
and which we have done in the past we
the use of gas chromatography for the
actual assessment of the fatty acid
composition of the lipids particularly
triglyceride or phospholipids in
membranes which are present in
biological samples and this hinges
particularly I think the assessment of
the amount of so-called omega-3 fatty
acid present it is looking at the role
of individual fatty acids not so much as
macronutrients but more as
micronutrients in the form of essential
fatty acids the n6 and ends three or
omega-6 omega-3 fatty acids are
essential for formation of membrane
phospholipids and therefore this can be
assessed in terms of the fatty acid
composition of any tissue you like and
the tissue will determine the time
integral over which it's a reflection of
the dietary intake of those particular
fatty acids so red cell did like an
hba1c would represent a three-month
integral of the fatty acid pattern for
that individual and the amount of the
individual fatty acid compared to the
total fatty acid composition would give
you a marker of of its relatives in
richland and so this has been employed
in what's known as the omega-3 index
looking at the the percentage of omega-3
fatty acids in the red cell membrane and
with interest in the possibility of
omega-3 fatty acids particularly marine
omega-3 fatty acids as having a
protective role in cardiovascular
disease this technique can show that
patient groups with low levels of
predictive fatty acids would appear to
be more at risk of cardiovascular
disease that those after intervention
who have higher levels and indeed just a
range between low level at
three-point-three percent of fatty acids
at a high level at nearly twice that six
point six percent of fatty acids would
would describe a change in the risk of
cardiac arrest of something like a
tenfold difference and so like 10
different value extent risk reduction
potentially associated with the
difference in the red cell fatty acid
composition between these two groups and
if we look on a population basis here we
have the cutoff for for probably an
increase in risk and it would seem that
in non supplemented individuals on a
Western diet the prevalence of problems
is of the order of around about fifty
percent just under fifty percent so this
could be a potentially useful test in
the general in the setting of the
general population at the moment we're
conducting visual trials where
individuals are treated irrespective of
their omega-3 status a question arises
as to whether or not better targeting of
treatment through the use of the Olga
tree index might yield better results
just conclude now by pointing out that
there are there some rarer lipid
disorders which some of which actually
involves low levels of lipoproteins low
levels of HDL of course could be a
problem
these conditions although rare are
extremely informative quite a few of
them have led to the development of
actual treatment modalities and of
course their investigation requires very
sophisticated techniques so using
protein chemistry molecular techniques
mass spectroscopy genetic techniques etc
etc however those techniques have
beneficial yield within the clinical
population because they have generated
useful treatment treatment options so
just conclude by summarizing in a number
of areas as far as total cholesterol is
concerned it's one of the components of
absolute risk assessment but taken in
isolation its confounded with respect to
cardiovascular risk because comprise
both anti and pro atherogenic
lipoproteins it's the starting point for
calculations that aim to quantitate the
amount of atherogenic lipoproteins
particularly LDL cholesterol which may
be being phased out and non-hdl
cholesterol which may be a useful
replacement HDL cholesterol we're
probably looking at mountain more in
terms of functional aspects but without
quite sure how we'll test that the
direct methods which are widely used at
the moment rely on selective recognition
of their that we need to remain
attentive as far as this is concerned
there may have been some interferences
with the early generations of these
tests and postprandial testing of HDL
there is a small decrease that occurs
postprandial in we'd probably need to
assess the degree to which fasting
should or should not be employed for HDL
measurement fasting triglycerides
standardizes the calculation ability or
cholesterol and defines levels for
diagnosis and treatment of
hypertriglyceridemia but it's a less
sensitive marker of cardiovascular
disease and mortality than postprandial
levels any form of triglyceride
elevation are the fasting or post
prandial may influence LDL composition
so
density etc and this is also reflected
in the inverse relationship between
triglycerides HDL cholesterol as a
summary the non fasting lipid and
lipoprotein testing may better reflect
predominant miss Pollock state may
better reflect the average Anissa T of
the postprandial state it may be
sufficient to provide the total of HDL
cholesterol needed for absolute risk
assessment it may be sufficient to
calculate the non-hdl cholesterol which
is becoming preferable over LDL
cholesterol and it may facilitate
patient management given that it's more
convenient for patient just to provide a
sample at any time of day rather than
having to present after 12 hour fast
presumably in the morning and so the
most widely non-routine tests can
provide potentially useful information
the most i think the epilogue appraising
measurements which are most relevant to
bring into more widespread use of the
measurement of m.o.b and lipoprotein
little a and other non routine tests
we're particularly looking for for those
tests which will give us quantitative
information and this tends not to be
available through electrophoretically
methods it's important to recognize
clinical features that identify causes
of primary dyslipidemia recognizing the
features of familial
hypercholesterolemia is particularly
important and therefore we should think
about saving very high levels of total
or more particularly non-hdl or LDL
cholesterol levels directing people
towards diagnostic tools such as the
dashed liver clinic score and pursuing
strategies such as family cascade
screening with or without genetic
testing the rarer causes of dyslipidemia
have led to important treatment
discoveries and they require
sophisticated laboratory methods one
test with demonstrated clinical use
buddy is the omega-3 index and probably
most significantly reliance on LDL
cholesterol is a diagnostic treatment
threshold or treatment target is likely
to diminish and a plausible replacement
something that's simple and practical
would be non-hdl cholesterol which is
simply the difference between total and
HDL cholesterol and it's already been
demonstrated business has bigger
clinical performance so thank you very
much for sticking with us I'll just
switch on QA but I realized that the air
is up and I'd be I nietzsche please to
respond to Christians now as they come
in in the next few days and months thank
you very much